I almost accidentally played one f4
hello and welcome to this rapid game I
mean I could do it come let's let's do
it for once I'm not really a fan of this
opening but if I get killed here
mercilessly because he'll class I think
that people avoid this in the future at
bad 96 okay huh that's an interesting
choice never considered this it's like
you made this before at 593 as well
and in those situations plug it now
often goes d5 I'm just not sure this is
a good good choice here I I didn't
really want to play a Stonewall thinking
more Leningrad reversed sometimes called
the polar bear so let's go III and see
what is planners proficiency form
probably ambition belong yeah I
definitely want to prevent him from
playing five we should be five maybe
wasn't alternative but okay I mean when
I played one F form it was kind of clear
that it won't be a normal game
that is a reasonable Stonewall it's not
so bad with a 19-2 bishop the bishop is
of clicker of course ok on g4 didn't
want to imply that this is there's a
problem with this piece but they're
blocked cheap on is a bit of an
annoyance with the colors reversed I
usually play Bishop III 92 NC 4
certainly something that black can do
here and this is by the way of a reason
why I am F 4 and one is so unpopular and
it's not like you don't feel up here
with what you don't feel at all that
you've got two white pieces yeah it's
just like if you would show this with
color servers it looks completely normal
there's simply no hint of white having
any sort of opening opening portion yeah
but the move like f4 will always be
somewhat play a long night before is
early but okay
castles I've felt to something that I
have to do
this Bishop f3 Queen h4 business is
something to watch out watch out for in
94 was over live that sometimes signals
the intention to play a counter
Stonewall with f5 yeah wonder if he if
he does that if I place your form get
something going
medium Bishop 1c one still really sucks
him with it Stonewall problem
yeah I wonder about you for maybe just
see form put some pressure and make it
more difficult for him to maneuver yeah
I like this it's a bit slow but after
this night before and so on that it
makes a little bit more sense
no nc5 wins apiece hmm
okay I was one idea to prevent that
regrouping
okay so I've won a piece for two pawns
how do I play from here
the only active p30 has a suspicion
let's do this and see only what he does
who p8 queen bee five gives me another
piece so I don't expect that one be six
I ever will weaken him and if he plays
yeah here I was thinking a form just to
and equals 85 I can't do this either for
984 just trade it that would be helpful
95 is an annoying move - it's extremely
annoying the bishop is attacked and I'm
threatening chicks
I'm not winning additional material
though can check on b5 King f8 97 even
and then King g8
maybe f5s dangerous ever and then know
that really next much so check here I
mean this is probably good almost no
matter wat KF a check I can take on b6
and then the Queen has to take we have a
that's watch nothing special
oh really okay
okay I'm just taking this
yeah I know f5 comes into consideration
opening everything in yeah that should
be good
Luke c8 I just go back
yeah he's a ticking c3 let's take on u6
definitely to move to check
I don't see a window it looks extremely
dangerous but I don't see a well take
takes is heaven the kinking can take I
can just grab here of course and I mean
hate is hanging at the end
look is hanging with chick queen III
check King e7 King be a queen b7 then
move the bishop and then save
let's see move early rook t8 never
really like to just take it and ignore
all the stuff in some fish until five
and it looks pretty devastating but
there is no real need for for any rush I
can just move the bishop bag but it
looks a little bit lame you want to take
care relent and finish the game
and maybe it takes community 3 Bishop g5
that threatens a 7 and f6e 7 check 6
looks completely completely over anyway
but I come to be 7 or something
yeah that should win that you 123 Bishop
g5
I overlooked something actually it isn't
so easily winning okay so let's check
this again in seven shake takes Bishop
g5 King right there is no immediate
knock out Bishop g5 f6 good now I was
thinking Queen d7 but 26 might still
hold water
okay yeah so x6 I know it sounds weird
but I don't see you in after that
probably I'm just totally blind queen
bee 726 where is the wing maybe look you
honor for e 7
[Music]
so even deaf six look in one is also an
option
[Music]
oh here
[Music]
okay cookie eight nucleate how do we win
against rupee 895 and threaten swoop f6
GTX Bishop h6 check King g8 Knight f6
mate at the q1 it looks good on 95
[Music]
[Music]
I feel I'm really missing easy wins with
a bit
yeah 37 is a pretty big threat
Kingi semanas couldn't be some here that
won't work
so I really only see Mookie Haines oh he
said I 7 is going
rukia it again yeah but again it's wrong
but I guess you know what I'm trying to
say but that looks right
so loopy 8 how do we kill this off our
Bishop is not hanging due to Queenie 6
[Music]
how do we end this now
95 looks generally attractive trying to
threaten on f6 just wonder if this is
too lame more than something else
look f6
come on use all the pieces do the knight
in the mix NS all kinds of things Knight
f6 Bishop f6 basically all the
sacrifices are now very substantial
threats
neither form also an eidm
you
[Music]
and removal
currently material is actually equal I
never counted
yeah I gave the piece back out on d3 for
this attack I don't know maybe it was
simpler to just play play Bishop sitter
yeah it's just made okay so let's have a
look at the analysis yes he yeah I was a
fairly normal looking position I went to
form trying to be more active there and
yeah then 97 was of course called
blunder which gave me the piece we
should play probably what does the
engine want to do castles something
normal
yeah there are a couple of options this
is one of them just develop c5 was
helping me of course here 95 or green
check not good check him so f5 is the
most aggressive way to do it
cakes yeah so maybe just bishops into
okay the engine wants to do this as well
yeah I actually played the engine engine
move so it was good yeah I wasn't
entirely sure because time here you can
also just play Bishop c2 and when I mean
here why this just appears up and and
the text so that's an easy solution but
this looks good okay this one
we have six and then you can already
already kill it with these seven oh I
wouldn't I look anyone I can check with
the look first
[Music]
yeah there's that stronger
I don't think man was really sports much
better
yes no way to defend but okay I should
have played e7 that's um that's more
more forceful okay guys I hope you
enjoyed the video thanks for watching